hi I'm slowly to our today's today I'd
like to talk about some of the games
I've worked on in the past I'm gonna use
this storyboard to point out some of the
stuff that I've done and some of the
stuff I've worked on so everybody check
it out before getting into the game
industry I actually worked for a funeral
parlor I'm not very good at drawing so
sorry about that
I Drive around in this sort of compact
truck with all the different funeral
supplies and stuff in the back
originally I was considering going into
the funeral parlor business full-time as
a career but at the time my wife came to
me and said is this really what you want
to do before the old multiple so this is
kind of what my wife looked like at the
time though maybe something like that
whatever so when I was thinking about
okay well what exactly is it that I want
to do that and I remembered that just a
little bit before that I had done a job
for Sega this one day when I was that
Sega there was a designer named Suzuki
you who came up to me and said hey I'd
like you to actually play Virtua racing
for me and design it is while you're
playing and see what you can do but
we'll go a little bit a little one thing
that surprised me was when I went into
the development offices there was all
these people sitting at desks playing
games listening to music on earphones
and they were all really young they're
around my age and I'm looking at the
different CDs they're listening to and
they're listening to the same music that
I like and it really kind of blew me
away because up until that point I had
this image of all the people who were
making games were sort of these like a
scientist a professor looking people
with white smocks and basically a sort
of cartoon mad scientist vibe oh yeah I
saw that there were people bleah my age
doing the same kind of stuff that I did
so from that point on I took an interest
in the game industry and thought wow it
would be really cool if I could work in
not just this place in particular but
just somewhere in the industry I went
home and I got a job seeking magazine
and my wife offered a lot of support so
I looked through it to see if there was
anything I could do that was related to
game
I found a place called human and a place
called Atlas that were looking for
employees
[ __ ] on that truth on it
so I went for interviews with human and
Atlas but was immediately turned away
from Atlas I got the job at human then I
went back for an interview to human and
ended up being turned away for a month I
didn't get any contact from them or
anything so I figured okay in that case
I'm just going to go back to the funeral
parlor thing and kind of give up on this
but my wife told me why don't you just
try and call them and see what's going
on I tried calling them to see if there
was something we could work out so when
I called them up they told me that the
director for the game FirePro which
actually ended up becoming my debut game
he quit all of a sudden and so they
didn't have anyone there who could write
or really do anything with pro wrestling
so they asked me sorry but could you
come back in right away for another
interview so I went back for another
interview and they hired me immediately
and that's how I joined the company
human humans hi basically this is how I
entered the games industry
well it's been so long since I've seen
any of this text I'm reading through it
and thinking wow I don't remember
writing any of this some of its actually
kind of embarrassing to be honest it
sort of feels like I'm reading something
that a completely different person wrote
a long time ago 100 hmm a whiteout
how did I forgot oh this is what happens
this is the main character the name
Smith morio actually came from the
Smiths and Morrissey little condo I just
really like the Smiths so I ripped off
the name for the character so right
around here where the arrows pointing
well that is just inside there Smith had
just committed suicide you probably
can't hear the sound here but this is
Smith's house and you can hear the sound
of a gunshot so I actually made two
endings for the game one ending in which
you win the match and one ending in
which you lose the match obviously if
you win the match that was the happy
ending lose the match that's the bad
ending we had the endings implemented in
during the debug and checking phase I
tried playing through it and it just
kind of felt weird and off to me and I
thought it didn't make any sense that
this guy's life would have two
completely separate possibilities for
the rest of his life based on whether or
not he won the match so I went to the
programmers and I told him look I
changed my mind
just get rid of one of these endings I
just wanted to have one conclusive
ending as for the reaction to the ending
it was really kind of a big deal at the
time back then the internet wasn't
necessarily a prevalent as it is now in
Japan we had this form called nifty
where people would communicate with each
other really simply online also called
it one more but most of the
communication in contact would get from
fans and users were in the form of
postcards and when we'd get postcards
about the FirePro games it wouldn't be
like hey I want you to put this wrestler
in the game or hey I want to see this
move in the next game mainly stuff like
that with people saying hey loved the
game didn't like the game or what
but once we put the game out and people
saw the ending we started getting these
huge cardboard boxes just filled
postcards and almost none of them were
nice fuzzy happy messages most of them
are saying stuff like what the hell did
you do with that ending what's wrong
with you you die
people were really kind of upset about
what we did and it really blew up I was
a bit surprised but at the same time
what are you going to do really it
really was a huge deal for myself and
for the company for a while afterward
today is the last day of GDC and I can
finally talk about this as it was just
announced this morning I'm coming back
to the fire Pro Series for the first
time in 25 years the upcoming scenario
I'm writing is called champion Road - so
it's Lowell and this time the main
character is the son of the original
main character Smith Morial the son's
name is blade cybo it's a little salty
though it's a direct sequel to the
well-known traumatic scenario called
champion Road from 25 years ago again
it's my first time coming back to the
series in 25 years and I'm really
looking forward to it let's see what we
can do when I was working on the fire
pro games I was working really late
every day basically from first thing in
the morning until last train at night so
usually past midnight and every day
between 6 & 7 o'clock in the evening
everyone else would go out for dinner
but I wasn't really eating dinner that
much and so I basically take a nap at my
desk put my headphones on and put my
head down the song I would almost always
listen to during these naps was this
song called grasshopper by UK band
called right
when I started up the new company I
decided to go with the name grasshopper
so I wouldn't forget what it was like to
be creating my first game looking
through this opening there's all kinds
of stuff that's really kind of flooding
back to memory a lot of it's really
nostalgic one thing that really kind of
stands out is nowadays people have
smartphones and PCs technology has
really kind of become easier to get your
hands on so pretty much anyone can take
a video and edit it at effects and
things like that but the time that
wasn't the case when we made this
opening we had to take a proper TV style
camera around the city and film a bunch
of stuff and then bring that into a
studio and have it all edited today it
could be done a lot easier but at the
time it took a lot of work this part
right here is Akihabara in Tokyo even
making this opening here I had to go
into the studio in Akasaka for days and
days doing the direction for it
the tiny tweaks and adjustments and
helping out with the editing with
Oakland with also those really nostalgic
even just these little things here with
the images kind of moving in from the
side and sliding across the screen I was
standing right there with the editor
giving really finely detailed directions
it just turned out that the guy dearly
didn't listen to me very much at the
time a lot of people still didn't think
very highly of videogames and so when
I'm sitting here with this guy telling
him ok put this image here you kind of
give me a lot of back talk like why do I
have to edit this it's just a goddamn
game what am I doing here and I would
tell him look this is just what I want
to make so please make it the way that
I'm asking you he really didn't like
what he was doing so it was a real
hassle getting this done properly
it also this is really nostalgic this is
the old version uh no as far as killer7
goes it's chock-full of memories with
Mikami at the time when we made the
prototype I think I redid the entire
first stage probably 10 or so times
process was I'd put the stage together
go to Mikami
maybe about once a month and show him
what we had and he tell me okay baby
changed this to make it more this way or
get rid of this then we'd go back and
remake it again this part too actually
I don't believe this is how it ended up
looking in the final game the crosshairs
the the style of crosshairs is a bit
different here but that's just a small
detail I happen to notice with killer7
I was just constantly concentrating on
it it really was like work and so I
decided with No More Heroes I wanted to
go in a different direction and I wanted
to make sure that I had fun making the
game it wasn't just working myself to
death and so what I decided to do was to
take all the stuff that I wanted to put
in the game and put it in there and just
get it all out I guess you could say
it's kind of like taking a [ __ ] on the
toilet I just sat there and got
everything out the way I wanted and it
felt great
No More Heroes is the game from which
the character Travis touchdown was born
in a way I was going in the opposite
direction then I had went with killer7
Travis and by extension of the game
itself was conceived because at the time
I was really into jackass and thought
johnny Knoxville was really awesome
watching Johnny Knoxville I thought he
was funny and stupid and he didn't care
but in a good way one day I thought what
if Johnny Knoxville was like a real Star
Wars super fan or taku type guy and what
if he got his hands on a lightsaber and
went crazy and from that idea the entire
game and character was born so I did run
into a bit of trouble with this when I
was pitching the game I said okay I want
to base this character off this guy
Johnny Knoxville
so I brought in some footage of jackass
to show the rest of the team and said
this is Johnny Knoxville this is the guy
I want to base this character on and the
footage they saw was Johnny Knoxville
standing there naked with little baby
alligators clamped on to his nipples and
the whole room kind of just went silent
and there was a real vibe of what the
hell is wrong with you at the time every
time I watched the clip I laughed my ass
off but when I showed that clip all the
rest of the staff just got totally
silent and just kind of stared like what
is going on here so Travis was born from
that sort of problem here's the beam
katana and and this was not inspired by
Star Wars that's what I've been telling
people for years for safety it was
inspired by ukg Gabon which is something
like space detective Gabon which is a
Japanese show from way back in the day
again that's what I've been telling
everyone for years just to be safe I'll
come on the girl bunker on the vehicle
dr. Bini you keep Tomas Eman well no
actually it definitely wasn't Star Wars
but it could have been
Spaceballs so that could have been where
I got the inspiration from but it wasn't
Star Wars visible to space water so no
problem whatsoever yeah
done with all this one aw master we
ended up making shadows of the damned
with ei and again this was another title
on which I worked with Mikami for the
first time in a while once again as
producer and director I've got a lot of
memories of the development of this game
with EA but but one of the things that
sticks out in my mind the most is I
guess you could say the battle with the
words western market throughout the
entirety of it I think there was about
three or so characters that we burned
through before we ended up landing on
Garcia shoulders are ye Sol Garcia was
probably about the fourth character we
considered weary hauled and redid the
script about five times and the fifth
version is what ended up becoming
Shadows of the Damned so each time I
rewrote the script we'd have to redo the
character because that's just sort of a
habit of mine and so the way the
character looks ends up changing as well
so each time I'd have to rewrite the
character I rewrite the script which
would mean the character would have to
be redesigned also EA kept telling me
over and over
fix this redo this if I ever happen to
work with EA on another game I'd really
appreciate if they would just okay the
first version of the script next time I
originally went to the states with
Kadokawa to speak to a bunch of
different publishers about the game we
were about to create and when we went to
Warner Brothers they said hey we've got
this director named James Gunn what
would you think about having him join
the team and maybe help out with the
game it seems some of his movies before
and so I was like yeah totally let's
bring this guy on and that's basically
how James Gunn came to be involved James
Gunn I'm a filmmaker I was brought in to
help craft the story of Ollie pop
chainsaw and deal with the actors and
after that he really kind of blew up
with the guardians of the galaxy series
and when he came to Japan to promote the
movie we go out to get a bite to eat
together and he even sent me an
invitation to the premiere of the second
movie we still talk even now and yeah
our relationship is still going on
I'd like to think that I could call him
a great friend he's just a good guy and
I'm really happy to have had the
opportunity to work with him and I hope
that someday we'll be able to make a
game together again I'm not sure if it's
okay for me to say this but I'm really
happy that James is coming back for
guardians three finishing demondo as far
as things I learned about myself
something I noticed was originally I
entered the industry as an idea man
having ideas for the pro wrestling games
I worked on one thing I noticed is that
I really really loved the process of
coming up with these ideas for games
from the ground up building everything
up from scratch I've been kind of
worried over the years as I got older am
I going to stop having these ideas am I
gonna start having trouble coming up
with new stuff to do but I found that's
actually not the case in fact as I grow
along with the industry you've got new
consoles new technology Google just made
a really big announcement the other day
I start having ideas that sort of fit
with the way the industry has changed
and technology has changed even today I
still really love just coming up with
ideas for games I'm not sure if that's
something you could say I learned about
myself but definitely something I
noticed is that I'm surely doing the job
that I'm meant to be doing which is
coming up with these ideas for these
games seeing what we can do with these
ideas to sort of push the boundaries of
the technology we have to work with one
other thing I learned about myself is I
just really suck at English I've been
coming overseas here to America and all
over the place for years so many times I
speak with so many people I come into
contact with English so many times but I
just can't seem to learn it it just
completely escapes me and there's
probably a lot of people out there who
are going to be like Suda come on man
learn English dude but it's just not
going to happen
[Music]